ken livingstone you won you were elected
there from the left I don't think
there's that much difference between
your policy positions and jeremy
corbyn's no we've worked together for 45
years I mean and I have to say in that
45 years and I think this is why
Jeremy's transformed this race he never
said anything he didn't believe was true
as a confidence comes out we were
chatting for we came on air there Sony
when you get to our age that confidence
comes Jeremy's got it you know he's a 66
was Margaret Beckett are more honest she
says put Jeremy Corbyn into the race by
nominating although she doesn't support
it hi I'm mark Kooy wishes to call
herself that I didn't really think much
of Margaret as Amorim but I think she
made a very very bad mistake yes they
did by really helping to put him in the
race I mean perhaps as many as 15 labor
and please nominated someone they don't
support it I mean we never used to have
this rule it was only introduced after
Tony Benn challenge there's always no
threshold hon no no it used to be just
nominated by two MPs and then after
turning in oh it's this big thing and it
is awful we know it's like something out
North Korea it's completely
inappropriate no people should be
allowed to just stand does Jeremy Corbyn
represent a set of policy positions that
could get labor victory of the next
election think not the party needs to
have Adam a much broader appeal and on a
narrow appeal I know Ken GLC labor mayor
victory twice and did a very good job
and London has had a lot to be grateful
to Kim for but as far as I'm concerned
Jeremy I'm sure it's a very good
constituency MP but we need a messenger
who can deliver a message to the public
he is not that messenger since 2005 Adam
he's gone against the whip over 25
percent of the time it's that leadership
is that someone who's going to bring
unity to the party I think not and I
personally I think we've got to gather
London bubble as well and to me I'm
supporting Andy Burnham
I think he has got the right credentials
to be the leader of the party I think he
can be the right messenger job for the
party but we all need to work
what the make secure him to deliver
include yeah I mean you are supporting
Andrew Andy Burnham but how would you
describe the overall quality of the
field leave your side Jeremy Corbyn well
I could just talk about the quality of
the person I prefer to say that and I do
believe that and he does have qualities
he did a great job in the Hillsborough
situation I think he's did an excellent
job of shadow health and I think he can
be the right message he's someone that
you could really you know touch him feel
and I think he's a human being and I
think he could really help take the
labour party out of its current mess
which we are in but will then take us
forward but I mean what what would you
say Ken listen to Tony Blair we've heard
from today and Tristram hunt and others
saying look you win elections from the
center if you take the party to the left
they're going to be furious if we didn't
lose the election this year because we
are too left-wing we went into that
election saying we're basically going to
be not quite as nasty as a tourist and
take a little bit longer that didn't
inspire today Jeremy's come out with I
mean I think the central issue more
investment to build a modern high tech
high school economy both Thatcher Blair
and Hammond have all seen appalling new
levels of investment and he's shown a
way you can he talked about investment
it sounds nice but what he's actually
talking about funding that for a more
borrowing and more text no no no he's
not really saying I don't know I've read
it and if you see he's using
quantitative easing the Bank of England
just created 375 billion pounds to prop
up the bank's hasn't fueled inflation
not done any desease over-rotate money
to actually invest in surviving the
bank's let's build a modern transport
system a modern broadband and he's
actually focusing on increasing taxes
for ordinary people but actually saying
to Google and Starbucks and Amazon
you're going to pay your fair share of
tax and if we get these international
corporations to pay their fair share of
tax you can reduce the tax burden on
British means say you can raise another
120 billion I mean that's not really
eligible is it tax avoidance new version
this country is most rocketing here 450
billion that's 10% of our annual cousin
residuals for as far as tax avoidance
tax evasion I completely endorse what
jeremy has said and I completely
individual yet
can't leave Ilyas without the messenger
delivering the message and Jeremy just
cannot be a messenger for a Labour Party
that's gonna have a broad appeal to the
electorate that's gonna take our party
forward you and I want NSYNC
we want to be back in power because you
know what opposition is not like LaVon
and he is not the person who can take us
there you said to me before until he
came in the race that you supported Andy
he's in the race so what go go back to
support and if Andy can take us for
Fangio jerem and Ewings I'll spend the
next four years campaigns getting
elected Larry when we had the Michael
foot leadership election I supported
Denis City
I love Michael foot I didn't think he
could win if I didn't think Jeremy could
win I wouldn't support it because I want
my kids to have a better future they
won't get that under a Tory government
but I think Jeremy connects with people
people stop me on the street
there really is a here's a man who says
what he thinks and believes and none of
it's frightening or scary you start
talking about investing in creating new
jobs or making the tax dodgers play
that's gonna go down well whatever I
agree about the tax situation totally
but as far as I can see concerned
I've just got a new grand journey is not
the person who is going to broaden
Labour's appeal if we're trying to go to
a narrow grouping of people can I'm sure
some of these people at playdoh know Ken
Livingstone I mean he is not the right
person to broad appeal and take us at
least the contest has got fascinating we
will be discussed